Ted py8 Minh author of Frank and Jesse
James the story behind the legend where
did you get an idea for this kind of a
book oh gosh that came about while I was
living in Nashville Tennessee back in
the mid 1970s and back about 1975 I have
decided for just the hecka that I was
going to for a year try to track down
everything I could on the James brothers
when they were living in Tennessee they
lived there for about four years from
1877 to 1881 and I kept finding more and
more new material and I just couldn't
quite put the subject down and about 20
years later I picked up and got a book
contract and started work on the book
and the end product is what you've got
there in 1995 you say Jesse James was
exhumed why they wanted to do some
forensic testing DNA testing professor
James stars and other forensic
scientists they got an excavation order
from the Clay County Court because there
was no no record of an autopsy having
been performed and the only way they
could do this was if there was no
autopsy of record and the person had met
their in through means that was somewhat
violent you might say and this was
approached more or less as regular
forensic crime examination just like you
would have in a modern instance whereas
Clay County Clay County is right on the
edge of Kansas City matter of fact I
think part of Kansas City is in Clay
County where is Jessie James buried
Jessie is buried up at Kearney Missouri
and Mount Olivet Cemetery
Kearney Missouri which is just oh maybe
about I'd say maybe 15-20 miles outside
of Kansas City were you around the
cemetery when the excavation was
conducted no I wasn't able to make it
over there but I did a good bit of the
research the historical research that
they used for finding out certain things
in other words they were trying to see
if there were any wounds that Jesse had
had earlier in his life that might be
visible say on the bones or something
like that or in one case there actually
was an autopsy and they cut the top of
the skull off and there were newspaper
accounts of it but again there were no
official records of this so they wanted
he died 1882 April 3rd 1882 how old was
he
gosh he was born in 1830 1847 1832 35 36
yeah something around that what did they
find in the autopsy or when they when a
dug amount dug him up they weren't even
sure that they were going to get him up
the remains had decomposed in certain
areas there and what they were looking
for specifically was DNA evidence but
they were also trying to look for
evidence of the the bullet hole in the
skull and things of that nature maybe
they could tell something about the
caliber of the weapon that was used to
kill him who killed him
Bob Ford under what circumstances oh
gosh that one is is is a hard one
Bob had ingratiate himself more or less
into the gang in a latter part of 1881
early 1882 but he was acting more or
less for the law enforcement people in
the Kansas City area and had met with
governor Crittenden and he was providing
information about Jesse's whereabouts
and they were possibly going to either
bring him in some way or other or
or is what happened in this case jesse
was straightening a picture or dusting a
picture by various accounts it's it's
not really sure boy which one is Jesse
James Jesse is the fellow that's
standing on the on the cover there in
the suit and Frank is the one in the
uniform who's older
Frank was older he was born 1843 and was
Frank there when Jesse James was killed
no Frank was in fact over in Lynchburg
Virginia at the time so you were
starting to say that Bob Ford was there
he was hanging a picture and pulled a
pistol on Jesse who had laid his guns
down on the bed and fired a shot and
that was it and they put the body up for
public viewing after they'd taken it to
the funeral home they had a number of
photographs that they took a body I have
at least one of them in fact in the book
and but there was this constant thing
that would happen every few years where
somebody would come forward say about
after the turn of the century and
claimed that he was the secretly
surviving Jesse Jesse James and there
would be some kind of big furor in the
press over this and it went on really
until the last claimant well even beyond
the last claim but actually they're
people that are claiming now that their
ancestor in Texas who died sometime I
guess back in the 40s
was was Jesse but there was the the last
living claimant there that actually
claimed to be Jesse that 1951 well you
know if you ask most people I think I'm
guessing
who Frank James is they look at you with
a blank stare if you ask them who Jesse
James is and they'd all say oh the
famous outlaw right uh but Frank James
lived a much longer life when did he die
Frank died in February of 1915 and
actually and my own personal impression
is that Frank had the much more
interesting life than Jesse did why is
the Jesse James legend so much more
known uh well it goes back to a lot of
folklore motifs that you've got there
of course jesse has the alliterative
name which sounds good in print and in
songs like The Ballad of Jesse James
that sort of thing and the other thing
is they you'll notice this with with all
legendary outlaws that achieve
immortality be it Robin Hood Billy the
Kid whatever they're all killed by
someone they trust and the Robin Hood
legend it's Prioress that Robin Hood
trusts Billy the Kid it's Pat Garrett
one of his former buddies in this case
it's Bob Ford one of the members of the
gang so it's all treachery why was the
governor interested in killing uh well
the matter of fact that's that's a side
point there I'm not sure that he was
interested in killing him the reward
actually was for bringing him in but in
this case Bob just went ahead and pulled
the trigger there I think he figured
that if I don't shoot him now that's one
opportunity blown and that we won't be
able to get him in and this fellow will
probably come back and shoot me so um at
any rate why did governor Crittenden
want one to get Jesse Jesse had been on
a train robbing spree and Crittenden had
campaigned for governor of Missouri on a
campaign platform that
included eliminating all of this
outlawry that was going on in the state
and it was getting big news headlines
all across the country you can see it in
the New York Times the Chicago papers it
had become a big political football and
both Missouri and on a national level
and Crittenden was a Democratic governor
who was and the Democratic Party was
sometimes being accused of taking a
lenient attitude toward this and so one
of his platforms was okay we're going to
eliminate the outlawry
and he managed to get funding from some
of the railroads to put up a huge reward
and this I think was the big factor
whereas these folks might have figured
well you know I'm not sure about doing
it when it in point of fact they were we
could make in one shot possibly the
amount of money that they would pull off
of a major robbery and reward and you
have to figure that I think what was it
was something like five or ten thousand
they were offering for Jesse you have to
figure that that's several times that in
current dollars you point out in your
book that they had SiC two brothers at
16 years of outlawry right you worked on
this book for 25 years right why it's a
fascinating story where were you were
you from originally from Nashville
Tennessee and this was how I got into it
there was a lot of material in and
around Nashville oral history of stories
that had been taken down and newspaper
accounts starting right after Jesse was
killed in fact and the whole four year
period that they were there had had
really been unexplored everybody that
had written on the Jane
story up to about that time was well
matter of fact I think most of the
authors were from Missouri and they had
explored all of the sources that were in
west of the Mississippi but they never
had come and done much in the Eastern
area so I figured well this is something
that really needs to be explored because
they spent a significant period of time
in the in the eastern United States
Frank like I said was in Lynchburg at
the time that Jesse was killed and
probably spent at least six months there
what were you doing when you first
started looking at all this was your
profession
uh I was at that time still in college I
was library student where George Peabody
College in Nashville Tennessee it's now
part of Vanderbilt University why did
you want to be a librarian I like to do
research and I found that I was rather
good at it well here's the book but I
later ended up getting a job over in
Missouri this was another thing that put
me closer to some of the source
materials that were over there and I
kept looking into this matter of fact we
had one woman that worked in the library
system that I was in whose it was I
think her her grandfather had been in
gadshill Missouri at the time that the
train was held up there and you start
your book with gadshill
right why this was the first train
robbery that Jesse pulled in Missouri
and it is kind of illustrative of the
typical train robbery that they would
have it was it was one that was rather
colorful because Jesse at the end of the
robbery left press release to be
telegraphed into the st. Louis
newspapers what year was this 1874
January of 1874 you have a picture in
your book of Jesse James and I have to
find it first in 1874 what
by the way there are many photos in here
that have not been seen before quite a
few actually yeah there are a number of
photos that if that are being reproduced
there for the first time that one is one
though that has been shot a number of
times that's that's around the common
one the one on the other page though
that shows Franck James's wife both of
those pictures are published there for
the first time the picture we're looking
at with Frank which one is Frank James
is 101 the far left this and there and
who are the other three people in the
picture those are her brothers and
sisters this was kind of like a family
photo that was taken in the 1890s after
Frank had surrendered which one of the
two brothers was the oldest Frank James
by how much mmm I'd say what was that it
was about four or five years see Jessie
James was born in 1847 and his brother
was born in 1843 according to your right
so there's four years difference right
and where were they born they were born
in the Kearney Missouri area I think
Frank was not born at the actual farm
but Frank Jessie was born at the what's
now the James farm which is a Historic
Site out at Kearney it's owned by the
county what were their parents doing uh
Frank and Jessie's father was a Baptist
minister as a matter of fact he was one
of the founders of William Jewell
College in Liberty Missouri it's not the
type of family background that you would
normally figure for a an outlaw just one
father here yes and he was uh had quite
a reputation as an evangelist in
Missouri he went out to California
during the gold rush and was in one of
the mining camps there just a few weeks
and came down ill and died
and that was pretty much it as far as is
a a matter of fact a number of people
speculated what would have happened if
he had possibly lived what happened
after he died uh the widow James Zerelda
Cole James remarried fella named
Benjamin Sims and Sims were and and the
boys apparently didn't get along too
well and they ended up being divorced
which was something that was rather
unusual for that day and age she later
remarried dr. Reuben Samuel and the
relationship with with Samuel continued
on until his death he died about I guess
it was about 1908 and she died about
1910 you've got a picture of her in here
yes that's her giving spiel for some
tourists by Jessie's old grave she would
sell pebbles off of the grave to
tourists for a quarter a piece and the
story goes that when she ran a little
low on pebbles she'd sent a boy down to
the creek bed and get a bucketful and
bring him back up there and replenish
the stock so to speak when I read your
book I found that you you said that
other than George Washington and Abraham
Lincoln more has been written about the
James brothers uh what what that is
about the James is is a historic sites
that have been saved as a result of
connection with historic figures there
probably been more sites for a
connection with Jesse James than for any
other person behind George Washington
and Abraham Lincoln have you been to
them all no how many of you been there
oh gosh
I've been to probably maybe about a
dozen or more what's some of the most
memorable the James farm at Kearney
Missouri and the house where Jesse was
killed but there's some some that I
found around Nashville that were rather
memorable also a matter of fact I
managed to get to those in a couple of
cases before the wrecking ball got there
and in one case we ended up saving one
house before it was demolished it was
actually a demolition order that had
been given out for the house but it was
enough historic neighborhood and it had
to go through a zoning appeals process
there and in the meantime the people in
the neighborhood got behind it and they
were able to find a buyer who was
willing to put up the money and restore
the house and it's there today as a
matter of fact it won a restoration
award by the Metro Historical Society
for the work done how many movies have
been made about Jesse James probably
about 30 to 33 something in that area
and matter of fact there's one that's
supposed to be coming out in August so
I'm bracing myself for another onslaught
there I guess why so many ah it's me
actually none of them have actually been
to historical I guess it gives a chance
for the script writers to kind of play
with the story there a little bit and
there has been some kind of popularity
to it it's jesse is sometimes called
America's Robin Hood so you have these
plots that involve Jesse and the
railroad and robbing the rich banker to
pay the widows mortgage that kind of
thing
was he a Robin Hood uh it's kind of hard
to say I think he was probably about as
generous as is anybody as a matter of
fact as there's a fellow that's doing
some research on this right now
into the widow story and it's very
possible that there was at least in one
case Widow who may have had something
contributed to by Jessie but we're still
in the in the process of doing some
research on that where does the legend
come from the legend wig legend you say
the story behind the legend the legend
comes from the media a lot of it comes
from the early histories there were
histories of the gang that were being
published even while they were robbing
trains there were in fact there was
there was one I wish they use this as an
illustration in the book there was a ad
in one of the st. Louis newspapers for
what was it the border outlaws of the
border bandits or something like that
by clarence Buell and one of the hooks
for the sale of the book was this new
train robbery that had occurred outside
of Kansas City so they were hooking into
that and they would publish this in
different editions and is each new
robbery occurred they publish an update
to it and afterwards you had a slew of
dime novels that were these cheap paper
they were about the size of say time or
Newsweek magazine but they would have
the content of a kind of like a modern
paperback Western although they were
even a little less than that and the I'd
say the ancestor of the dime novel would
be some 1950s television series is on
the Old West where they'd have one one
stock character in there that would go
through a series of adventures Buffalo
Bill jr. is one that pops to mind where
they would have this one one character
there and he would be dealing with these
other famous people in the Old West that
maybe have a Wild Bill Hickock
or Jesse James or whatever and they go
through you know however many adventures
they could dream up basically and the
name was literate if and the the Robin
Hood image was was brought out very
often so you had this myth in this
mystique that developed over the years
how did you talk a publisher into this
book uh that came right a little bit
after I had discovered the Pinkerton
ladders Allan Pinkerton was a detective
in charge of the Pinkerton Detective
Agency and he kept a book that had
copies of they call them press books
they were blotted off copies of all of
his old letters and one of the key
ingredients of the James story is the
raid on the James farm in 1875 January
of 1875 where the detectives came in and
tried to catch Jesse and supposedly
through this bombshell into the house
there and there was a debate going on
for over a century as to what the story
was there and lo and behold I turned up
a cache of these letters if Pinkerton
had been thinking clearly I think he
probably would have put these through a
shredder but the picture area yeah
that's Allan Pinkerton as a younger man
and the picture beside it is the grave
of one of his detectives that was killed
by the Jameses right after the gadshill
robbery and this put him in a very
vengeful mood
and one of the other detectives had been
killed while trying to apprehend the
younger brothers and so according to
some of the letters that I turned up it
appears that Pinkerton intended to burn
the house down there and had gotten
certain flammable liquids or solids or
whatever uh some kind of annex
pyrotechnic device that he was going to
throw into the house there and I
remember one of the the quotes and one
of the letters was above all else burned
the house down I know which house is
this this was the James farm the old
cabin out in Carney is just about three
miles outside of Kearney Missouri and it
appears this this scene appears in a
number of movies where they they
actually throw a bomb as it was and it
blows up and my Samuel or the the the
mother of the James boys ends up being
killed decades before she actually was
killed and it's a it's an ingredient of
the legend but this actually showed that
the Pinkertons were this was a little
bit more than an accident I guess you
could say just the same Pinkerton name
that we see today that the agency yes
that's security
yeah and you say in your book that he
did some work for Abraham Lincoln yeah
yeah he did some work as a counter
espionage agent in the Washington and
Virginia area during the early part of
the war when McClellan was in charge I
don't know how well he did the work
that's sometimes hotly debated there but
this is the same gentleman clown that
ran against Abe Lincoln and a yes before
was was Pinkerton political uh probably
was to have gotten away with some of the
things that he did um it matter of fact
one of the letters that I have in the
book is where he is is pleading
with the governor of Illinois not to
allow the extradition of any of his men
to Missouri because there were murder
indictments that were issued out of the
Clay County Court for the raid one of
the half-brothers of the James boys
Archie Payton Samuel was killed in the
raid when this device that they had was
pushed into the the fireplace there blew
up and in those 16 years the Frank and
Jesse James ride together all the time
Oh for a good portion of it after Frank
James settled in Nashville and Jesse
settled in Nashville they came to kind
of a parting of the ways
Frank was starting to settle down and he
had found employment with a lumber
company in Nashville and I think he was
trying to get out of the business there
how many did they kill people oh yeah
how many do you know my Theresa Jesse
may have killed as many as six or eight
and that's just kind of a guess the bulk
of the killing that was done was
probably during the Civil War period and
we'll never know how many of those there
were but I think they may have been
something like six or eight that jesse
is credited with so what was the first
year that they got involved in any kind
of activity do they fighting us of war
yes they were out in Missouri with the
guerrilla groups that were under
Quantrill and bloody Bill Anderson who
was Quantrill Quantrill was a guerilla
leader out in the Kansas City
independence area and the fellow
underneath there is a sequential right
here ponch holds there and then they've
got another picture of Anderson later in
death be dead here yeah they had him
posed for that just to be sure that
there weren't any legends that sprung up
around him oh I think there were some
people that later claimed
Anderson but the the gorillas were
operating along the Kansas Missouri
border and then later in Central
Missouri and then over in Kentucky they
later some of them ended up under
Quantrill in the area around Bardstown
Kentucky
so they put 16 years marauding stealing
killing uh let's say the the first
actual robbery that was pinned on the
James brothers was the Gallatin Missouri
robbery they robbed a bank in December
of 1869 this is the first one that they
actually have some reason to feel that
that they were in although there there
is some evidence that Frank James may
have been involved in another bank
robbery in 1866 outside of well in
Liberty Missouri matter of fact they
call it the Jesse James Bank Museum it's
still there today and you can go in see
the bank vault and the counter and
everything pretty much as it was back at
the time of the robbery and they do it
arrived a special way oh they just more
or less came in rode into town I think
they were about a dozen or so people
some of them went into the bank some of
them more or less hung around out the
streets to keep an eye on things and the
folks in the bank one of them hopped
over the the counter there had a flower
sack and more or less said fill her up
and they took I think what was it was
something like about $60,000 worth of
button money and the go stable
securities and maybe even some non
negotiable securities and there also but
they were fencing these they found some
of the bonds as far away as Cincinnati
at least how much this was going on back
down how many other gangs were there
besides these two uh at that time they
was probably I don't know the one that
pops in
mine is the Reno Gang out of Indiana
around Seymour Indiana and they were
more or less wiped out in I guess
there's about 18 68 or 69 there they
were actually the the first people that
are credited with having pulled the
Train Robbery is this your first book
yes and it's published by Cumberland
house yes where are they they're in
Nashville and you say the Pinkerton
letters would really got their attention
yes what else got their attention and it
wasn't hard to sell them on during this
book uh actually it was not going
through Cumberland House at the time
that a matter of fact that this thing
had quite an odyssey there it was
originally contracted to Rutledge Hill
press and Rutledge was a little did I
know well they'd published a number of
other books was it I can't think of a
mine offhand but there's one of these
gift books uh they had a number of
cookbooks and historical books they did
the thing for the what was at the
History Channel series on the Civil War
Journal and some other things but in
this case they were interested in doing
this and I turned in the manuscript
about five years later and got a
telephone call one day and they said
they couldn't pay me the second half of
my advance turned out they had run into
his financial wreath they ended up
ultimately being absorbed by Thomas
Nelson publishers and as part of a deal
with one of the one of the people that
had been a partner in Rutledge at the
time that the contract went through
had left the company and set up another
company and in connection with with some
debts that were owed there I was kind of
treated like a football or baseball
player and so were a few of the other
authors there and this ended up being
published by Cumberland House now how
does your book fit in to all the books
that have been written what's so special
about this that you couldn't get in any
other book Oh
basically what I do is take all of the
new research that's come in from about
1966 right on up and told well just
about the beginning of 2000 I've turned
in the chapter the final revisions there
in January of last year and prior to
that the best book was probably and
actually it still is a very good book I
say my book is actually supplemental to
dr. William settles book Jesse James was
his name which was published by the
University of Missouri and the
University of Nebraska Press are there a
lot of James followers out there yeah a
surprising number surprising they meet
every year is there a club yeah they
have friends of the James farm and
another group the james-younger gang and
they meet out in the Kansas City area
and there's the the james-younger group
is supposed to be meeting in San Angelo
Texas sometime this fall I think who's
who are the youngers and how many of
them were there oh let's say there was a
Bob Jim John Kohler about four it's all
cold yeah and where were they in this
whole Bay they were uh over in the Oh
where would it be they were from
originally another County over Cass
County one of the sons of a judge right
Henry Washington younger was a County
Judge over and
Cass County and he was a unionist
and oddly enough he ended up being
murdered by Union militia during the war
it got incredibly complex incredibly
bloody it was more or less like Bosnia
over there and Cole was had joined up
with with Quantrill and served with him
for a while and then later got in and
got a regular Commission in the
Confederate Army as a captain but he
came back and they had a number of these
folks had problems settling down there
were a coal claim that he was having
problems with with Union sympathizers
that were persecuting him and so forth
and whether that's the case is is
somewhat debatable but robbing banks was
a very quick way of getting cash in
those days and the confederate veterans
that the guerrillas very often were a
little bit shy of that right after the
war so you say that there were six eight
murders where the James brothers over
that time I would Frank James did he's
killing about it you know oh yes number
of them matter of fact he probably
killed the bank teller Northfield
although that was kind of hushed up for
I don't know several decades right up
until after his death Northfield what
state Northfield Minnesota how important
was that robbery that pretty much
spelled the end of the james-younger
gang the youngers were captured right
after the robbery at Northfield it was a
badly bungled robbery they tried to get
in the vault of the teller claim that
there was a time lock on there and
there's some question whether he was
bluffing them there but they didn't
bother to check
and they assumed I guess that it was
locked and in the meantime the
townspeople heard that the bank was
being robbed and were out in the streets
with shotguns and old Civil War carbines
and anything that would shoot basically
and they just barely managed to get out
of town alive and right after that they
had several thousand folks after them
combing the state in posses it was one
of the biggest manhunts I think
Minnesota has ever had before or since
and the youngers were captured I guess
it was about two or three weeks after
the robbery and the James is somehow
managed to give the posses the slip get
on a cross to just about where the
Dakota line is and then slip down into
South Dakota and Iowa and then somewhere
down in that area and the they managed
to get back to Missouri apparently as an
aside you say that Frank James was a
Democrat but changed to be a Republican
right why and we might heed by Teddy
Roosevelt this is in his late year yeah
he thought Teddy Roosevelt was a man of
action and he personally admired
Roosevelt the legendary 1912 story of
the shooting of Roosevelt and Milwaukee
is in your book right why because Frank
offered to raise a bodyguard of a
hundred men to protect Roosevelt and he
sent a telegram off to Roosevelt's aide
offering this and the fellow this was a
secretary the fellow that'd had tackled
the would-be assassin there and I think
he was probably thinking oh my gosh how
are we going to deal with this because
in one way it was kind of a it was a
possible plus but at the same hand it
was also a possible - that you've got
this fellow that is noted is is a
and it in an outlaw threat saying that
he's going to raise a group of
bodyguards here so he kind of
sidestepped it and said well mr.
Roosevelt is is not planning on doing
any campaigning further here but we want
to thank you and he wants to say that
he's feeling as hearty as a bull moose
and Frank was such a supporter of the
bull moose party there in fact that he
used to call the livestock in at his
farm by yelling as loud as he could bull
moose and yeah did Jesse James ever go
to jail oh there is a possibility that
he may have been just for maybe a few
about an hour or so maybe held in jail
at Liberty Missouri he was ever tried uh
no and he died at age 35 36 right but
Frank James buddy was he ever tried yes
as a matter of fact he went through
several trials at least two full trials
that I know of what happened to him
who's acquitted in both cases um one of
them was for the Winston bank robbery
and not the bank robbery it was it was a
train robbery Winston train robbery
which was one of the last things that
the gang did and they it was kind of
vague as to whether Frank had had been
there at least they were able to prove
that he might not have been I think it
was basically a matter of reasonable
doubt whether he actually was or not
that may be another story but he was
able to beat the rap there and in the
case of the Muscle Shoals Alabama
payroll robbery I think he was actually
in Nashville at the time the robbery
occurred and there was some pretty good
evidence to indicate that I went over
the depositions and it looked like they
had a rather weak case there during this
time that you did this book over 25
years how did you support yourself
uh work as a librarian at first and then
for a number of years I was looking
after two elderly parents and I
literally I was absorbed with dealing
with that but whenever I had some free
time I'd go out and do some research on
this then I've done historical research
on the side for number of other people
that are that are authors where do you
live today College Park Maryland and
where have you lived Allenby lived there
oh I've lived there for about a couple
of years and before that did you move
out of Nashville anywhere else and
lifted Hagerstown Maryland for a few
years and what was your reason for
moving to the East Coast out of
Nashville I had relatives over here and
I put me in close proximity to the
National Archives in the Library of
Congress I just wanted to move over here
now this book in your own life how
important is it it's it's a major
milestone I'd say yeah it's it's
something I really wanted to do and I
feel that it was worth it it ended up as
runner-up for the Best Western biography
and the Western writers of America spur
Award it may not have taken the top
prize but I feel that it's something and
I feel that I've also managed to shed a
little bit more light on this particular
subject here what can we learn from this
story oh well there are a lot of things
as a matter of fact it shows the effect
of media on celebrity for one thing I
think in the current day and age if you
had something like this the the media
slant would definitely be very different
than it was back then
but it also shows the the influence of
politics
on what was going on at that point in
time out it was way out in Missouri it
became a very politically charged case
and rather intricate the Democrats were
accused of not taking sufficient action
in the matter of the James brothers
running around Missouri and trying to
apprehend them and so forth and this
ultimately came down to governor
Crittenden and the reward and so forth
there but they did a rather ineffective
job of hunting them down for the first
Oh decade or so at least and it was only
after Crittenden got in and posted the
the rewards and some of the jesse at
this point in time was had made some
some very bad blunders he had apparently
killed one of the members of the gang
and this didn't go down too well with
some of the other people although he
didn't come out and apparently
advertised this matter of fact I think
that gang killing had something to do
with Bob Ford plugging Jesse there was a
fellow that named Edie Miller that had
taken part in one of the holdups outside
of Kansas City was a the fabled Glendale
train and the Ballad was the Friday
night the moon was bright when they
robbed the Glendale train the conductor
on his knees delivered up the keys to
the outlaws Frank and Jesse James and
this was celebrated in the in the ballot
and but it didn't go down too well with
some of the people as it started to leak
out and I think this was at least in the
back of Bob Ford's mind when he pulled
the trigger it was he ever convicted
anything Bob Ford actually believe it or
not after he shot Jessie was tried for
murder and was convicted and sentenced
to hang and governor Crittenden
telegraphed a pardon and just like that
so this shows kind of how things were
going there Jesse had not actually been
brought in formally and charged they
never served the papers or anything on
it there was a large percentage of the
population that thought maybe he was not
guilty of any of this that he was being
persecuted by the Republicans who were
using this for political gain this is
what I mean by by how this became
politicized over there so in the late
years and there's a chef you have
outlaws of the sawdust trail yes what's
that chapter about that's about Frank's
a career in show business and that
started I guess it was about 1901 Frank
had tried running for the was it the
doorkeeper of the Missouri legislature
and he had been thwarted in this however
Democrats are in control
yes he was Republican well he wasn't a
Republican at this point he was a
Democrat matter of fact that had
something to do with why he he switched
parties but he felt that he had had
lived an exemplary life and so forth
after all of this business and that he
was entitled to be shown some something
for for all of this
so when he was passed over for this
position he decided to go and join a
traveling theatrical troupe and was in a
number of melodramas that were put on in
the Midwest and even only at least as
far east as Pennsylvania's as far as I
know and then as far west is maybe
Montana or Idaho
who is John Neumann Edwards John Newman
Edwards is the fellow who is often
credited with being the creator of the
James legend and he was a newspaper
editor he was editor of the Sedalia
Democrat and the st. Louis Dispatch and
several other newspapers but he is the
one that issued a number of Florida
editorials defending Jesse James and
saying that he was being persecuted and
all of these robberies however he was
careful to delineate were being pulled
by someone who is very clever and very
theatrical and so forth so he would he
tended to to kind of blink at what was
going on there and he later I had a good
bit to do with Frank James when he later
came in and surrendered he was brought
in by Edwards who had a lot to do with
negotiation there between the Missouri
authorities and and Frank and he also
apparently had a lot to do with some of
the wire pulling in the trials there
what we're did Frank live out his life
and he died when he was like 72 yeah he
died at the James farm but he lived
several other places he lived in Nevada
Missouri for about a year or two I guess
sold shoes over there this is after he'd
had this history of a crime yeah and
then he went down to work as a salesman
in the department store in Dallas Texas
people know who he was oh yeah they were
using him as a draw this was this was
one of the things the the fact that you
had Frank James working in your store
there would bring in just crowds of
people there so uh he ends up I think he
was he was working as a race starter for
a number of years matter of fact I think
he
did that right on up until close to the
time of his death and uh was as a
doorman in a st. Louis burlesque house
for many years and have any money when
he died apparently he did he was
apparently making some big money there
for a while when he was going on stage
who is your favorite character in all
these uh I'm trying to think I guess it
would probably be Frank James he was the
most interesting one to do the research
on because I never could figure what I
was going to turn up next on him there's
a picture of him near the end of his
life
yeah that's with the fabled Kodak's
Baird sign and that has an interesting
story to it the the thing was he was he
was running the James farm as a tourist
attraction then and the sign is it was
painted said Kodak's Baird he up there
in there in the left hand corner yeah
and what would happen was tourists had
come in there and say hey you got your
your sign painted wrong there said bet
you five dollars I've got it right and
the people would would figure well I've
got an easy five bucks coming to me here
so they would say you're on and said
let's go on out there and look at it
Frank had penciled in the other are in
Baird you couldn't see it if you weren't
looking real closely and he'd win the
bet invariably and some people said that
he was kind of carrying on the holdup
business and another another guys with
the with the tourist trap there that he
ran but that's the story behind that
picture who was Jesse James married to
did he have children yes Jesse was
married to some of Zee Mimms who was
actually his first cousin and they had
what was that
several children those are the two that
survived I see and Susan know this yeah
Jesse Jr and and Susan and Jesse jr.
both of the the bar and the James family
that they have descendants to this day
that are living the the bar the
descendants of Susan there's at least
one that I know of that lives out in the
Kansas City area
what impacted the name Jesse James have
on jr. Oh
he lived the rest of his life more or
less in the shadow of his father he was
accused of having taken part a train
robbery when he was in his teens and it
looks like there was some pretty flimsy
evidence there but they figured well
they were going to pin it on him and he
ended up going to law school and was
actually an attorney for a number of
years and I think he was more or less
trying to live all of this down but at
the same time he couldn't quite get to
the point where he accepted that his
father was really the outlaw that he was
and he invested very heavily in a set of
movies Jesse James uh under the black
flag and Jesse James the outlaw and they
didn't do too well financially and he
went over the edge afterwards and had a
nervous breakdown as a result of this
and he never did quite get over it there
it was a major disaster in his life who
is Frank married to Frank you showed the
picture there at one point this was um
any ralston now that's that's an
interesting story she was a
schoolteacher and one of these little
one-room
schoolhouses and place called little
Santa Fe Missouri which was just south
of present-day Kansas City matter of
fact it may even be in the city limits
of Kansas City at this time that picture
the bottom is of her when she was about
16 and she was married to she was the
daughter of a fairly well-to-do farmer
outside of Independence Missouri
Sam Ralston who is actually Irish and
had come over from Ireland and uh she
eloped with Frank and her parents didn't
realize all I knew is that she had
eloped with someone and they couldn't
figure out who it was and one day about
a year later I guess this is about 1875
or there abouts the one of one of
Jesse's relatives in Kansas City came up
and said oh by the way your your son
your daughter just married my my cousin
here Frank and it just kind of put these
people through the floor and
particularly so when the Sheriff's Posse
started making regular appearances at
the house there whenever they'd be holed
up they'd be the members of the posse
looking out as to the premises there and
this just infuriated the father-in-law
and the story goes that Frank wouldn't
get down off of his horse when he first
met his father-in-law after they had had
gotten married he came back to the
independence area but he would
supposedly wouldn't get down off of his
horse I think he was afraid the old man
was going to beat him up or something
there
we're out of time I need to ask you in
write another book probably about well
uh it might have something to do with
the Jameses
but I'm looking at something else baby
possibly having to do with the Old West
we're out of time our guest has been Ted
P Yeatman and this is what the book
looks like Frank and Jesse James the
story behind the legend thank you very
much thank you